hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone from
Fandango movie clips and I'm not gonna
lie I'm pretty excited right now because
I get to explore the brand-new Wizarding
World of Harry Potter here at Universal
Studios Hollywood I just got off the
Hogwarts Express
now I'm in Hogsmeade and I'm gonna take
you with me let's go
I'm so excited to be joined by work
Davis does it feel almost like you're
back on set I mean more so because that
the detail here is just as good as we
had on the film except here you can walk
through one of the doors and the
interior of these places also exists
it's fully immersive I've read about
these in the books the every flavor
beans now tell me do they actually have
vomit flavor yeah literally every flavor
let's see what I get a slice now see now
that one's good I think they're all
delicious
okay here we go I think this is a vomit
silence
yeah I survived survived the vomit bag
oh we know that the wand chooses the
wizard
shall we try my dear yes oh my my my
Alohomora amaura hora hora hora
Alohomora
so I'm here with James and Oliver Phelps
aka the Weasleys I am pretty excited
because I think I'm an honorary Weasley
myself more so than we are yeah what
happened to the ginger it all went back
in the bottle at the end of the last
film which is actually a good thing for
me I was in the robe shop and I was
thinking I wonder how much it would cost
to go to Hogwarts have you ever done the
math I haven't no but it's like any
other boarding school I'm imagining it's
not well the fee is free but apparently
there's a lot of damages yeah I was
gonna say me would technically be a
magic comprehensive school as they call
in England like a state school yeah only
without the graffiti and the smoking in
the toilets maybe it's Moaning Myrtle
yes it's probably worse over here and
after a long day at the park the best
way to finish off is with a nice cold
cup of butter beer I've always wanted to
try this I have had the best time
exploring the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter here at Universal Studios
Hollywood if you'd like to check it out
yourselves go to the Universal Studios
Hollywood website for all the ticket
information and for more Harry Potter
content keep it right here on Fandango
movie clips i'm elisha malone juice